cette femme célibataire vous avez
peut-être pensé que j'étais du folklore
pas tellement si nous avons fait ça ça
répond réellement besoin
à la campagne la trouve plus h marie eba
crowley on a fait jeu qu'on fait pour
les x
la célèbre foire aux dindons de shangai
a donc une concurrente la foire aux
célibataires la petite localité
limousine qui veut devenir la première
commune matrimoniale de france exploite
à sa manière la polémique qui oppose
susceptibilités corrézienne est bretonne
on a fait courir le bruit que nous
allions faire c'est revenir comme le
bateau sont pauvres
c'est de la blague c'est toujours pour
en revenir à ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure c'est le folklore sans cesse ses
délires thouars on m'a raconté ce matin
la préfecture qu'on avait fait passer
notre service n'est ce pas pour que
toutes les jeunes filles toutes les
dettes il au monté en graine qu'elle ait
plus de 25 ans de rester inscrire à
chénérailles l'inspiratrice de la foire
aux célibataires et conseillère
municipale dans son commerce des
bibelots des pendules des solitaires et
des alliances
vous avez une confidente dans notre
magasin les états d'âme en tout bien
tout honneur
suivant notre guide nous avons battu la
campagne à la recherche des hommes seuls
vous irez cette foire aux célibataires
si je peux retrouver une brute un calcul
et l'avenir c'est comme se créer un
foyer à t'envoyer sauver ta famille
vivant
toujours rigolo elle est ambassadrice
conjugale de chénérailles c'est beaucoup
plus sérieux vous ne pensez c'est
beaucoup plus que nos pensées nos
campagnes se dépeuplent tout ça c'est
uniquement parce que nous n'augmenterons
pas se marier sans savoir
on vit bien à la campagne n'oubliez pas
que jean guitton redit la creuse sur un
joueur paulois où les gens des villes
seront heureux de vivre
c'est un pays absolument rien pour moi
il rien pour l'instant j'ai un point
d'attaché si quand même bon prix étaient
travaillées maintenant je pense je
trouverais avoue marié facilement te
faisant bouillir toujours plus est vous
qui avez vatan vous irez à la foire aux
célibataires ceux qui sont seuls sont
ceux justement qui ont des petites
propriétés ceux qui sont dans des
grandes arrive à se loger parce qu'ils
on arrive ici peuvent arriver à
installer un certain confort
ce que vous auriez une solution la
solution il faut encourager l'unité des
propriétés pour leur entrée dans les
ordres rentrer dans les ordres je ne
suis pas une raison suffisante
anick lemay voir s'il vous plaît mais
par nous avons encore quelques questions
à vous poser
brisson des timides ils vont en un ils
ont en retrait vis-à-vis des autres ils
ne vont jamais au vase
ils ne vont jamais dans un café
sympa alors mademoiselle expliquez-nous
votre cas si ce n'est pas vrai mariage
oui alors vous êtes vous êtes pour lui
on libre je suis très heureuse de mener
cette célibataire c'est tout bas côté
autrefois mort mon père était
autoritaire et figurez vous qu il est
inconscient ex concierge et est un vieux
garçon est alors ils nous disaient mes
enfants mon avis pourquoi vous mariez
pas à guy monsieur melon bien que des
vous savez s'accrochèrent une chose il
vaut mieux aller acheter un litre de
lait tous les matins que d'avoir une
vache armée dehors
la prestation de celles qui viendront
seront très bien accueillis
monde nous essayons dé recevoir le mais
profitant à vin d'honneur à la mairie
puis on les invitera un déjeuner et puis
après lorsqu'elles seront bien emprunt
eh bien on fera une petite sauterie